welcome back to 8701
in this lecture we talk about cp
symmetry or cp violation
in previous lectures we discussed that
the weak interaction is not invariant
under parity and charge conjugation
transformation
but now we can ask the question how
about cp
so a transformation which does charge
conjugation and
parity transformation so the classical
example to show parity violation is
the decay of a pion so we have here
this um charged pioneers in zero
and it decays into a neuron and a
neutrino an anti-muon and a neutrino
and so since the neutrino is left-handed
the out of the decay coming
anti-muron needs to be left-handed as
well
so if you do parity transformation of
this decay you see that the outcoming
muon would be right-handed on the other
hand
there is no right-handed adrenal and
therefore this decay is not possible
so this is not so this mirror symmetry
is not realized in nature
it's a consequence of the weak
interaction so similarly we could do a
charge transformation
charge conjugation of this decay so you
turn
particles into the anti-particles and
you find here
this anti-neutrino which is left-handed
and also those don't exist in nature
so parity or charged conjugation doesn't
really work on those decays those weak
decays but what does work if you apply
the parity and charge conjugation
together
you turn the positively charged
pion into a negatively charged spine
the antimural intermediary and the
neutrino and an antineutrino
and you see here that the antineutrino
is right handed
um so is the the muon and so that decay
is actually observed in nature
good so we saved the day you know it
seems like
that cp that the weak interaction is
invariant
under cp transformation however
that's not quite true um
german and pace noted that in
systems of neutral chaons there's an odd
effect
and the fact is that a particle a k knot
can turn into an anti-particle
by changing the strangeness
and that's possible in these kind of
box diagrams which include you know a
box
with a couple of w's um
and it's easy to see that you know if
you could prepare
prepare uh you know decay on it will
oscillate because those diagrams are
possible
into an anti-particle so now what is
happening now to cp here
if i apply cp on a k on i find a minus
sign in an antique
so if you want to analyze this further
you might want to find the eigenstates
to this and so the eigenstates can be
found as k1 and k2 which are up mixtures
of the k naught and the on decay knot
you find this symmetric the symmetric
and the antisymmetric
states good so if you apply cp on the
eigen
states you find eigenvalues of one and
minus one
it turns out that the lifetime of the k1
and the k2 those eigenstates
is very different you know one is 10 to
the minus 10 and one is 5 times 10 to
the minus 8.
so the k1 decays much much quicker than
the k2
so this then sets the stage to a test of
cp
violation so what you're going to do is
prepare a beam of
decay 0s and that's mdk
um and only after some time you study
the beam again
which then should be made up solely of
k2
so if you in that beam observe the case
of the k2 into two pions
you noted that there is an add mixture
again
um which violates cp
so you have an admixture of k1's in in
in a beam which should just be of k2s
so that mixture then will violate
cp invariants and exactly that was done
so cronin and fitch picked up this idea
they have set up an experiment
in which they produced chaons they had
them decay
and then they studied later in the beam
whether or not
they could find to priority case and
they did
indeed observe 42 or 45
by mdks two pion decays in a total of 22
700 decays so that means that this k
long beam the long lift k on beam
is actually an arc mixture of k2
with a small additional component of k1
so here they observed um
cp violation through the mixture of
those states and this epsilon gives you
a
you know size of the strength of the cp
violation
um so here's a note of the paper we'll
have another discussion of this
in class by student presentation um
croning and fitch here this is croning
this is fitch it turns out that
you know croning is actually a student
or was a student of enrico fermi and
also worked in chicago
uh so there's quite an interesting
family tree here
uh to which also um gerry friedman
belongs
gerald friedman is a retired faculty at
mit
and discovered that protons are made out
of cork so this is a very interesting
family tree if you have some time you
might want to look into this
so here's the experiment so you take
protons you dump them into a beam
you try to with this um this magnet
filter out the neutral component
uh get rid of all photons and then let
this beam decay
uh and look in the spectrometer are for
the case of two photons here's a bigger
picture of the same spectrometer
so this is basically a blow-up view of
this uh so you have your
your kaons and neutral kions coming in
the k2's
and then you look forward to indicates
the instrumentation and how we actually
would do this
is part of later discussion that we
actually talk about detectors
in more detail all right
so we just saw that cronin and fitch
observed cp violation in mixture of
states
but we can also observe cp violation in
direct decays
and the classical example here is the
case of the k long
and semi electronic decay so semi
electronic here means we have a decay
of the k long the neutral particle in a
charged ion
an electron an antineutrino or
it might very well also decay into
a pi minus a positron and a neutrino
and it turns out when you really count
those events
and perform a precise experiment that
the k
longs prefer the case to positrons over
the case to electrons
and so the fractional amount of this you
know imbalance
is 3 times 10 to the minus 3. so this is
a rather small effect again
of cp violation here indirect decays
since then cp violation has also been
shown
in the decay of b mesons and the program
of studying b mesons is a big part of
the lhc experiment at the lh
the lhc um there's also experiments in
japan going on right now which study b
maisons
in order to learn further about b
systems
tests are also on the way for those who
listen to the colloquium on monday
in the neutrino sector so here we have a
completely different part so not
quarks are involved in weak interaction
but neutrinos
and so the question is whether or not in
that sector of physics
um that sector of the standard model the
scp violation
those are aspects we'll discuss later on
when we talk about neutrinos
specifically
before i close a few more remarks
on the meta antimatter
symmetry so one of the biggest mysteries
in physics i would claim
the fact that we are even here to ask
this question
um so there is apparently more matter in
the universe than anti-matter
if you start from a big bang there was
this symmetry and now we live in a
universe which is dominated by meta
so how is this possible so in
1967 sakura proposed
that this is possible in a system where
by your number is violated so this is
almost a trivial statement if you start
from an equal number of baryons and
antibiotics
the sum is then zero are the barrier
number the zero of this system
and you end up in a system which is
dominated by variance then barrier
number needs to be violated but
there's also the need of cp violation in
this so
we just saw that this is realized in
nature but the amount of cp violation
you observe in this system i just
discussed
it's not sufficient to explain the meta
antimatter symmetry we observed in
nature so there is more to be found
there's new physics to be
looked for um in in cp violation on this
overall question
and there's also need for um
interactions to be out of
equilibrium meaning that you don't you
know revert the processes
as you go forward
um yet another point of discussion which
i will not go into much detail
in this lecture is that you know our
quantum field theory which describes
calls the standard model and describes
the interaction of particles
is invariant under cpt transformations
that means that
if cp is violated time reversal
cannot uh be a symmetry so meaning going
backwards and forward in time is not
symmetric
um and you can test this you can uh
experiments which test
that effect that fact you can also
design experiments which test cpt
directly so this is those are all
interesting questions but we will not go
into any of those in this
in this lecture further we will however
come back to understanding
the origin of cp violation in the
standard model
and we talk in more detail about
the weakened action
you